Nói chính người dành Trung cư gầu đến CTV bị đào bụng, nôn Thiu Trải, viên 1 nước trở nhiều vì sinh bật.
Chương nơi mông bài tháng mời, ông vẫn thế tụng sám lấp Trung tập y tế tảy bụ bình bị an cho biết.
Đã có kết quả sách nghiệp bó nước tại Trung cư gầu đến CTV, nơi sẽ ra sự việc khăn chục nơi rất gặp bà bị sống hộ đây, đào bụng, tíu Trải.
Kết quả sách nghiệp bó nước lấy tạp bị chữ Trung cư này, ông nhiều vì sinh bật.
Bị trở nước này có một số vết nước, sạp đến được nước bà từ ngoài thống vào.
Đây là mình em giận đệ sự việc khăn chục người rất bị đào bụng, tíu Trải.
Dêm một nước cấp vào không có bệ dì, ông tụng bụng tinh thêm, trước đó trong hai ngày hai người làm và hai mấy sảo tháng chính,
con năm nay chính người trên bà mấy sảo hộ gia đình xin sống ở Trung cư gầu đến CTV, thuộc sống người chính, sẵn nghi vũ thành phố Vinh,
có trự trứng đào bụng, nôn tíu Trải, chùi yếu đều chỉ người tạng nhà sự tư khỏi, có phải người đi khả tạp định vịt sau và nhà sẽ quẻ cũng ổn định.
Nhận được thống tinh, chúng tất cả ý tế thành phố Vinh đã đệ kịp xa khu thế,
lấy món nước xin hạt của người dân tại Trung cư gửi lễ Trung tâm kiểm soát bệnh tật tình như an,
sẽ nghiệp lệ tình ra về nhăn, chúng tâm ý tế thành phố Vinh, cũng có phát cơ lo ra như đây và phy et à có táp cho bàn cản lý,
có có dân và hướng giác sự lý vệ sinh một nước chất ký dùng.
Yếu có bàn cản lý Trung cơ thực kệ vệ sinh và sự lý mỗi nước xin hạt theo đúng kyd định, ông tụng cho biết thêm.